they queued in london
stood in line in manchester
and waited patiently in edinburgh
evidence across the uk of the demand for
protection from omicron and an instant
response to the call to get boosted if
you have an appointment you can come
over here centers like this will extend
opening hours and work seven days a week
as the nhs pledged to offer everyone
over 18 an appointment by the new year a
promise hampered when the system went
down on the very first morning we have
had some glitches on the system but
please my message to the public would be
do keep trying more slots are going on
all the time and certainly some services
are also offering walk-in services so if
that's available near you
please do take that opportunity
the first dose vaccine program peaked in
march at a seven day average of just
over 500 000 doses with a single day
record of more than 750 000 the second
dose wave peaked in april at almost 416
000 a week with a single day record of
almost 557 000. the booster program
averaged almost 426 000 last week with
more than 550 000 doses delivered on
saturday
to meet the new target it will have to
eclipse all those records
nhs england says it will offer everyone
who's eligible for a booster jab an
appointment by december the 31st and
that appointment may well bring them to
a pharmacist vaccination center like
this one boris johnson wants everyone
over 18 to have the jab by the new year
that would be 18 million people in 18
days four of which a christmas day
boxing day and bank holidays it would be
unprecedented
and unlikely
even getting close will be a huge
challenge and rely on increasing
capacity at 3 000 small-scale pharmacy
gp and pop-up sites
i think the the challenge for us is
about how we really get into supporting
the nhs and the government with this uh
you know this ambition
we're looking at all sorts of mechanisms
by which to do that so whether that's
expansion of the vaccination centers
extra hours that we'll be operating
and releasing as many appointments as we
physically can
in northern ireland as elsewhere those
on the front line do not underestimate
the task
it is a big ask however we are not
working alone we are working with the
gps and with our community pharmacies
and together you know if we pull
together it is achievable 750 military
personnel will assist with planning and
delivery and tonight the welsh
government has committed to the same
targets as the other home nations
britain a country united in building a
wall of immunity to try and keep the
virus at bay and our freedoms alive paul
kelso sky news